We have a hairy looking expression here
and your goal is to try to simplify it
as much as you can. I'll give you a little
bit of time to do it
Let's just think about it step by step
It might help if you were actually to
reorder the terms
in this expression
So let me put all the "x" terms first
so I have"5x" that's that term
minus 2x
plus 7y
plus 3y
then I have "+ 8z"
And then I have minus Z
and the last term that I haven't included yet
is "+5". Right over here
Now let's just think it through.
If I have 5 x and I were to take away 2 x
how many x would I be left with?
Well I would be left with 3 x. That's true
of anything. There's not same fancy
algebraic magic going on.
5 of anything minus two of that same thing
You're going to be left of 3 of that same thing
In this case that "thing" is x
So this is going to simplify to 3x
Now in a lot of algebra classes you will hear
people say, "Oh, well the coefficient on 5x
is 5 and the coefficient here is negative two
and we have to add the coefficient
(let me write that word down)
these right over here are the coefficient
they're the number that your mutiplying
the variable by
So the 5 or the negative 2 in this case
you could just so
Oh I can just add the coefficient
and that's ok. There's nothing wrong with that
but I really want to emphasize
there's a very common sense intuition here
You have 5 of something
you take away two of that something
you are left with three of that something
you have to make sure that your adding
and subtracting the same thing
here we're dealing with x's
so we can take 5x and take away 2x
we can't think about merging the x and the y
at least, not in any simple way right now
because frankly that would make any intuitive sense
now let's think about the y
if I have 7 of something
and I were to add 3 more of that something
then I would have 10 of that something
so this part right over here
is going to simplify to
10 y
once again you could say the coefficient
on 7y is 7
the coefficient on 3y is 3
we added the coefficients (7+
3) to get to 10y
but I really want to emphasize the intuition here
If you have 7 of something you add another
3 of something, you have 10 of something
now let's look at the Z
if I've got 8 of something
and I take away one of them
I'm going to have 7 of that something
that is 7z and you might say hey
what was the coefficient here on the -Z
I don't see any number out front
of the z. Well implicitly I could have put
a one here.
It's exactly the same thing.
Subtract a Z is the same thing as
subtracting 1z
the word 1z strikes a part of my brain
because I have very young children
but that's a different type of 1z
and then you can see yeah you definetly
did add the two coefficients
The 8 and the -1
but once again common sense tells you
that if you have eight of something
and you take away one of them
you have 7 of that something
and then finally you have a plus 5
so we're done
this simplified to 3x plus 10 y plus 7z
plus 5